[Music]
i think it's going to surprise people
you kind of sit there and go how did
they do that
it's going to be different from any
superhero movie ever made
there's no one better in the world to
direct the suicide squad
than james gunn i was excited with an
opportunity
to be able to do the suicide squad in
the way it could be done from my point
of view
this one is completely unique this is a
gritty 1970s war movie
combined with brilliance of james gunn's
characters in comedy
you need your director to set the vibe
the suicide squad is just a twisted
fantasy of characters within each of our
characters there's a certain beauty
within most of them some of them are
just pretty crappy through and through
be like a douchey captain america the
guy who believes
in peace at any cost no matter how many
people he needs to
kill along the way okay i got it
don't ever settle back like you think
you know where this is going because
you don't as soon as you have some sense
about what's about to happen next
james comes in
everyone's exploding genitals heads arms
legs
it's like a big massive graphic novel
brought to life this is by far the
biggest movie i've ever made
i don't think that you know what to
expect
don't get too attached this has been
truly
the greatest most exciting
journey of my life making this film
cut that was great you know the deal
successfully complete the mission you
get 10 years off your sentence
[Music]
welcome task force x these are your
brothers and sisters for the next few
days
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my video for the suicide
squad trailer that they dropped at dc
fandom this weekend
we found out who all the characters are
playing we got a bunch of footage
there's a bunch of easter eggs so i'll
explain where this
fits in the justice league dceu
continuity
and how this relates to the first
suicide squad movie there were a bunch
of other trailers that dropped this
weekend i'm doing videos for everything
so be sure to subscribe to get all those
videos i'm also doing a giveaway for
this giant box of dc fandom merch that
they sent me so all you have to do to
enter is just be a subscriber let me
know
which new super weird suicide squad
character is your favorite
the way they explain this movie is that
it's sort of a soft reboot of the
franchise without completely retconning
the events of the first film but it does
take place
after the events of the first film it
also takes place after the events of
justice league obviously the justice
league snyder cut doesn't really change
the timeline that much it still takes
place
relative to where the other films take
place but it also takes place after the
events of the birds of prey movie even
though it doesn't necessarily reference
a lot of stuff
in that movie most of what you see from
harley quinn will just reference her
history with the joker even though james
gunn did say that jared leto's joker
does not appear during this movie they
obviously
have to reference each of the characters
backstories in some quick hilarious way
so when they're referencing harley
quinn's backstory they'll just reference
the events of the previous film briefly
her history with the joker and her
history with ben affleck's batman
in gotham but also ben affleck's batman
does not appear during this movie either
even though he's coming back for the
flash movie
i'll do a separate video for the flash
movie teaser because they just revealed
a whole bunch of big stuff about that
film
the way they're describing this film
though is that it's a gritty 1970s war
movie as they say during the trailer the
cool thing about that is that matt
reeves
just said that the batman movie with
robert pattinson is based on gritty
1970s cop shows in the movie chinatown
and joaquin phoenix's joker movie is
also based on that same gritty 1970s
aesthetic
so all these crazy dc movies seem like
they're going heavy on the 1970s just in
terms of style so if you really like
that aesthetic a lot of these films are
going to feel like that too
but just to be clear the batman movie
with matt reeves is an exception to the
continuity it's not really connected to
justice league or the suicide squad
movie
that exists in its own separate
continuity i've already done a video
about that trailer so i'll add a link
for that at the end of this and in the
description because it was badass but
this new version of the suicide squad
gets caught up in a foreign war they
didn't say where the war is happening
but from all the footage it just seems
like it's somewhere generally in the
south american region
probably going to be some big location
from dc comics history
some of the bigger surprises though are
peter capaldi playing the thinker
obviously there was a version of that on
the flash tv show but peter capaldi's
version is a much more comic book
accurate version like you can actually
see the nodes
sticking out of his skull that they have
for his prosthetics
really happy to see this version of king
shark i have a really big theory about
how they're going to pull that off
in taikawati's quote-unquote mystery
character
nobody guessed who idris elba was
playing in michael rooker too big
surprises so i'll explain
all the characters with some of the
bigger justice league dceu easter eggs
that connect this to the other movies
but the premise of the movie is simple
there's a foreign war that amanda waller
is forced to deal with so she sends in
the suicide squad to handle it
now during the footage you see them
rescuing little girls but it also seems
like they're trying to topple a dictator
in a foreign government
which is a very suicide squad thing to
do they don't do a lot of
large-scale assaults on foreign
countries they're more of a surgical
group that amanda waller sends in to
topple foreign dictators when she wants
to get rid of them when they become an
inconvenience to the united states or
the organization
for the price of 10 years off their
sentence they complete the mission as
she says you get 10 years off your
sentence which is also a bit of a teaser
for
sequels if this movie does well enough
which it seems like it will it seems
like it's going to be the biggest
craziest movie ever
but some of these characters for
instance have done things that are so
terrible that they probably have
consecutive life sentences
on their terms so getting 10 years
knocked off doesn't really help them
that much
so they'd have to go on a ton of
different missions in order to
meaningfully reduce their sentence
but the funny thing about this the whole
tagline of the movie don't get too
attached quote unquote
just to let you know that are definitely
going to kill off some of these really
ridiculous characters
i'm looking at you nathan fillion and
flula so if you feel like some of the
characters costume just make them feel
super crazy and silly it's probably
because they're going to kill them off
in hilarious ways during
the movie for instance nathan fillion is
playing a character called tdk that is
not a character from dc comics history
but early theory
tdk the initials stand for the
detachable
kid as in a version of arm's fall-off
boy which was an early theory people had
about his characters but early
predictions he's going to be one of the
earliest characters that they kill off
in some hilarious way
i also love that they're doing king
sharks so big and crazy he almost seems
like he's going to be a version of king
shark from the harley quinn
animated series the more comedic version
because get this yes you do see him
running through the trailer just eating
people
left and right anything he can get his
fins on but steve agee is the one doing
the motion capture for him running
around on set like you see him in that
giant
harness but the theory is is that taika
wattidi who's listed prominently in the
credits but doesn't appear during the
trailer
is just doing voiceover for a character
he's probably gonna do the voice over
for king shark
so king shark will just run around in
the film sounding like a kiwi while
eating people left and right
think about king shark just running
around sounding like korg in the movie
they also finally confirmed that sean
gunn is doing a version of the weasel
character from the comics this is what
he looks like in the movie like really
really horrific but it's probably gonna
be kind of hilarious too
it's funny to see him going from playing
rocket tiny raccoon
motion capture on the set of the
avengers films and guardians of the
galaxy
to also playing a larger rodent-like
character but i don't know if he's also
going to do the
voice of the weasel character 2 or if
they got somebody else to do that
i love how john cena is saying that his
peacemaker character is like the
douchiest version of captain america you
could possibly imagine and that's how he
played him during the movie
idris elba's character actually has a
bit of a cool backstory that ties into
some of the justice league and the
superman movies
so he's playing bloodsport nobody
guessed that but in the dc eu
he's been imprisoned for shooting henry
cavill's superman with a kryptonite
bullet so obviously this takes place
after the events of justice league when
superman has come back to life but
because he's a mercenary he was hired by
jesse eisenberg's lex
luthor so just a little bit of extra
superman story going on in the
background
i don't know if that means that henry
cavill is going to cameo during the film
because there were a lot of rumors about
him signing a new contract to show up in
a couple different dc movies
there's a way that they could do that
superman scene of him shooting with the
kryptonite bullet without actually
having to have henry cavill on screen
you could just have him off in the
distance being shot with a kryptonite
bullet but it would be way cooler just
to have him on screen for like two
seconds while they do that backstory
scene i'm really interested to see how
they explain mon gao
because she's the daughter of mongol in
the dceu so we know that he exists out
there
somewhere even though we haven't seen
him on screen there's a lot of
space-based dc movies like the green
lantern corps that we just haven't got
to yet where we would see those
characters
so hopefully at some point they'll get
around to making that new green lantern
core movie or maybe they'll show up
during the hbo series and they can do
war world during that
harley quinn has a couple new badass
costumes she's gonna be crazy as always
you've seen so much of margot robbie's
harley quinn that i feel like you kind
of know what you're gonna get
going into one of her movies you all
know about captain boomerang joel
kinnaman's rick flack amanda waller
all them coming from the events of the
first film david dostmartian is playing
polkadot man obviously one of the more
ridiculous characters cannot wait to see
what he's like during the movie
michael rooker looking crazy with that
white wig is the savant character i
actually thought that pete davison was
playing savon
but he's just another character who's
really good with hand-to-hand combat so
just expect michael rooker to be super
crazy
you all probably know flula from either
his youtube channel or the other comedic
stuff that he's been doing recently in
the movies but his javelin character is
actually from the booster gold comics
there was a booster gold movie that they
were going to try and make at some point
that was going to be a comedy i don't
know what happened to that
maybe we'll see him show up somewhere
but let me know in the comments which of
these new characters are you most
excited about obviously that's not
all the brand new characters that are
going to be in the film there'll be a
bunch of easter eggs but the way james
gunn talks about it it's going to be
huge
and crazy and nobody has guessed the
plot completely
the movie's coming out in august next
year around this time so we probably
won't see the next
really big trailer until sometime early
next year
but if they drop any more footage or
promos or anything like that of course
i'll do a video
there will be more trailers for the
justice league snyder cut i'm still
doing a video for the flash movie teaser
for the black adam movie teaser and i've
already done a video about the batman
trailer so you can click here to watch
that a billion more times
and click here for all the other dc
fandom movie trailers
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]